I am here to talk about time,
which is obviously everyone's
favorite subject. In particular,
I'm actually here to talk
about a package called clock.
So clock is a date time
manipulation library
Kind of in the same way that
lubridate is a date time
manipulation library.
It does things you might
expect add dates, subtract
dates, format and parse them.
All kinds of other manipulation.
If you get anything
out of this talk,
it's really that
clock is not here
to replace lubridate in any way.
The only idea would
be that in the end
clock might be a back end
for lubridate in the same way
that dtplyr or dbplyr
are different types
of back ends for dplyr.
And I'm not even going to spend
the rest of this talk talking
about features that
overlap with lubridate.
Instead, I want to
talk about things that
are pretty unique to clock.
One of those is safety.
And one of those is calendars.
Because I only have 5 minutes,
I'm going to do that with one
date, January 30th of this year.
Safety is built into
clock from the ground up
to hopefully avoid issues
like this, time zone
issues, invalid date  issues,
things that are pretty common
when you're working
with time series
and just drive you up the wall.
So let's jump into safety.
Here's a timeline.
This is January 30th,
our date in question
marked in blue on our timeline.
It continues
through to February.
On the next line, you'll see
this gap between February
and March because
February only has 28 days,
but January had 31, so it
doesn't necessarily map 1 to 1.
If I were to ask you this
seemingly innocuous question.
Please add one
month to this date.
What would you get?
Well, if we were
to ask lubridate,
it gives you a somewhat
reasonable answer of NA.
There is nothing that maps
1 to 1 from January 30th
to something in February, maybe.
And there's nothing
particularly wrong with this
except for the fact that it's
not the most useful answer.
Generally, you'll
be running this code
and it happens silently.
And then five steps downstream.
All of a sudden, you discover
there's some NAs here.
Like, I didn't have
those to begin with.
Where did those come from?
And you have to backtrack
up through your calculations
and figure out why they appeared.
If you were to ask clock
this question with add months,
it actually gives you an
error in this special case
by default. It
says, whoa, hold up.
There's something wrong here.
Go look at location 1.
If you had a vector, it might be
location five, seven, whatever.
And check out the
invalid argument
to learn more about this case.
You go and you look
at the documentation
and you come out with
the idea that maybe I
could set this thing called
invalid equals previous.
That allows you to say, give
me the previous valid date when
I have this kind of problem.
That's the end of February.
I think that's a pretty
reasonable result in this case.
But you also might
want to say, depending
on your specific problem,
invalid equals next to map
forward to the
beginning of March instead.
if you actually do like
that lubridate behavior,
that's fine.
You can say invalid equals
NA any time that occurs,
you'll get an NA instead.
So that's about safety.
Let's talk about calendars.
Calendars are just
the idea of a way
to represent a
unique point in time.
With our date in
question, we could
use a calendar called
year month day
to represent this date using
three components the year,
the month, and the
day of the month.
But this isn't the only way
you could represent this date.
You could also use the year
and the day of the year,
or you could use one of these
many other calendar types that
are built into clock.
If your finance
person, you might
be particularly interested
in year quarter day,
which uses a true fiscal
year to represent your date.
These are really nice
because they're all
convertible to each other.
You can work with any
particular calendar type
and say you need to
get the quarter out.
You convert to year quarter day,
you do manipulation over there,
you convert back.
It's obviously convertible
with the date in POSIXct
as well, since those are the
date time types that you're
most likely to start out with.
The other really
neat thing that I
find really fun about
these calendar types
is that they have what's
known as variable precision.
These are all day precision
calendar types at this point,
but we could narrow that down
to month precision as needed.
And you've got a built-in
year month type in clock.
Similarly, you could have a
built-in year quarter type.
You can actually go
the other way, too.
You can widen it out all the way
to nanoseconds if you need it.
The last thing I'll
say is that clock
is completely compatible with
some of the other packages
you might be familiar
with that I've
created called slider and IVs.
Slider is one for
rolling averages,
so you can use clock
types as the index to say,
give me a rolling average.
looking back four
or five quarters
IVs is a relatively new package.
You might not have
heard of this one yet,
but it deals with
date ranges and you
can use clock types as the
components of those ranges.
So to sum up, lubridate
is not going anywhere.
Don't worry, but please try
clock for enhanced safety
in these powerful new types.
Thank you.